oh my god
american horror story is she gonna
rewrite everything circus
he's gonna get away get it get him get
him
welcome back to new rock stars one
division just went
full house of m and i think in those
words i just said full house by accident
because malcolm in the middle was really
the name of the game this episode
everything was terrifying this halloween
pietro probably ain't pietro
and we are left asking wtf
or wanda
i really needed to get that one out
because i have a lot of questions
this is inside marvel it's our one
division after show i'm eric boss here
with jessica clements hey jessica how
are you doing
i'm doing good i feel like we're getting
our wanda the answer though
a lot that well a lot and not a lot of
this episode
i was getting really mad that like
pietro was asking questions but wanda
was not answering them
i was like these are all questions i
have and uh pietro kind of gave us uh
some more questions with the way he was
behaving i think
we learned a lot about what marvel plans
to do
with this hex and it looks like give us
a lot of uh
new things in the mcu like um how big
this hex will grow
could tell us how this could set up both
the
multiverse and the mutants in the mcu
and uh people may laugh but i really
think pietro
might actually be mephisto or someone
like that
after all and not the mutant from the
fox x-men franchise
every episode is you know going back and
forth keeping us gassing
it's amazing i see where you're coming
from but i also think
i don't know i think pietro is just
pietro and like a fake pietro
but i think all right the real creatures
within agnes
and i can't wait to explore that this
episode because it
it's clear that it is just agnes yeah
we're going to talk both about agnes
pietro everything that you were confused
about this episode
and that's in this episode tomorrow is
going to be my in-depth shot by shot
breakdown of all the easter eggs that
you missed
will that stop any of you from coming on
this video saying that you missed a
certain easter egg no
not at all but this isn't the breakdown
where we do that i do that in tomorrow's
video
people don't get things it's hard you
heard him you heard it
oh uh a special merch announcement
before we begin there is a special sale
going on at newrockstarsmerch.com
we're calling it a vision time day
sale oh
so here's how it's gonna work from now
until 11 59 p.m on sunday
the 14th you can get 10 off new
rockstars merch by using the code
vision time day or by clicking on the
link in this video's description
ten percent off uh all new rockstars
merch it's it's a great deal
uh and one of those things you can get
is our new latest obsession shirt that
i'm wearing an unusual couple it's got
secret augmented
reality easter eggs just like the show
has secret easter eggs that you have to
like kind of cross your eyes to see
you can get one of these for yourself or
for your sweetheart at
newrockstarsmerch.com
and if it's too late to get delivered by
valentine's day you can also just get
them a gift card to the site
and if you get the shirt you will get an
extra opportunity
to write in a custom shout out that's
going to appear at the bottom of these
inside marvel after shows
uh look we got a couple great shout outs
we're going to read for you erin maya
said first anniversary shout out to my
hubs ty
he's deployed and wanda vision plus nr
is our weekly virtual date
that is amazing thank you guys so much
and uh and thank you for your service we
appreciate that uh to all of our uh
active duty watchers we we appreciate
you
um i cover a military family i i get the
sacrifice it ain't easy
we got oh renee saab says which uh
magneto
do you think will should appear um
you're the best from maddie saab
aka masa which magneto yeah we did a
video on the channel this week about um
why it might not be ian mckellen
fassbender might be the way they're
gonna go
we'll talk about this episode i think
magneto might show up and then michael
talbott
asked do did the twins bring over
quicksilver they seem to be in control
of reality and know
know it when they age up yeah these kids
at least
wiccan or we'll call him you know billy
for now seems to have some of the
sentience that
his mom has right um i don't know if
they brought on
again we'll talk about pietro yeah and
he might not be quicksilver we are
simulcasting this live on stereo holy
smokes we got over 1200 people listening
right now
you can get this live podcast app for
free and follow
us at stereo.com new rockstars if you're
listening to us on stereo right now
stick around for a bonus segment at the
end of the show
in which we will react in real time to
the voicemails that you guys
leave for us and if you miss the live
broadcast uh don't worry
you can catch us next week we go live
here at 8 a.m pacific
stereo dot com new rockstars all right
jessica
what happened this episode time for my
weekly
i'm bad at summarizing but we will try
to get through it
i try no i'm not i want you to
summarize it so much quickly and i'm
like we i just talk fast
all i do is just talk back some people
are like we can't understand that idiot
you should run auctions stop what you're
doing right now go to options
so let's see which one is an auctioneer
okay so
so we are now in the 90s oh that's me
trying to do the 90s or like
it's like 90s late 2000s right yeah yeah
because it's malcolm
it's obviously malcolm in the middle
with that font baby with that
font and i love knocking on the middle i
love mocha in the middle and
basically piatro's francis if he didn't
go to boot camp i'm saying it right now
but so we're in like yeah uh
2000's like late late 90's i think early
2000's whatever what have you but it's
malcolm in the middle
petra is the cool wacky man-child uncle
of course
uh they're all dressed up for halloween
and their comic book like designated
attire that they are
not what they are in the normal mcu
which is like a cute homage
uh wando pietro and the boys prepare to
go trick-or-treating while vision goes
to protect the streets with the
neighborhood watch
wanda and pietro discuss why he looks
different and we get so many quicksilver
references in the span of five minutes
and
i was i was like okay i get it he's
quicksilver
but when wanda goes outside and starts
talking to herb and realizes her oh my
god herb i see
i love him no you have to call him
because he is a plant he's a doctor she
goes to talk to paprika
and realizes it realizes vision
isn't actually working with the
neighborhood watch that night he's
obviously doing his own kind of
investigating now he knows what the
world's going on we all
get that vision is wandering to a
different part of town where obviously
he's like everything is out of character
not because it's halloween but because
it's just a weird world and obviously
one vision is
just upside down it's very emotional for
some neighbors to be putting up uh
decorations that single tier very very
laggy halloween it's their last
halloween it's very sad
um meanwhile with sword monica and
hayward get into a fight about the
missiles that they shot at wanda
and hayward issues them to be kicked off
the base and then once escorted they
just kicked the ass of the people taking
them off yeah real lacks security at
that sword camp
right like they're wandering around for
an hour and no one seems to
find it weird we're not trying to be
that person but jimmy wu and monica are
the only two people like constantly in
those close-up meetings
you think you wouldn't notice monica
just wandering around the camp still
yeah she's kind of a celebrity but you
know hey uh a poncho is more mcu
disguised in a ball cap which is
normally what they do
the poncho would just soared
they did good costume design okay so
that happens then we get a weird shark
90s commercial
oh my god that like animals like
where a child dies from starving though
holy crap
yeah this poor kid what just he can't
get the he can't get the yo magic yogurt
open
and he turns into a nazi from an indiana
jones movie he does he does he
literally melts his face and just dies
it was so
weird they're just like they truly are
going off the rails now
they don't care they're trying to scare
the crap out of all of us after that
yeah after that creepy commercial wand
and pietro are talking again where he
summarizes he's here to play his part to
stir up trouble to fight the
brother-in-law to stir up some grief in
her
stating it's what wanda wanted which is
like now like wait what are you talking
about
they talk about how they have no accents
in this world what happened to your
accent
what happened to yours i love that they
both called each other out i
was like where's your accent elizabeth
olson is like oh right
she was asking the questions but there
was no answers he was she was like
where's your accent where's your accent
and i was like okay he retaliated what
is it and she went
and stayed silent so really stupid
questions that i needed answered
so he's like they talk about why they
don't have accents without talking about
it and the last moments of pietro have
are wanda screaming his name and then
him just going fuzzy and hazy which is
like
ding ding ding it's because it's not
your memory dude it's not your memory my
dude
okay so back at sword monica darcy and
we are trying to hack into the computers
on the base to see what hayward is
really up to
which he is tracking vision's corpse
with decaying vibranium
yeah we we can talk about that but like
right off the bat we know that hayward
is like
using him as like raw material to
weaponize stuff so
really all vision is the hayward it's
just decaying vibranium
also can vibranium decay it's a metal
i didn't know that either but may i
don't know we'll talk about it okay so
darcy finds monica's
blood work in haywood's computer and
anytime monica
went in and came out of the freaking hex
her cells just like mutated
they like gollucci mutated yeah that
implies like dna
right like big deal i like i also want
to like stand right here put a stamp and
say that voz
said that she always had the powers and
i was like i think she's going to get it
from going inside
the hex and look what it's turning out
to be
you're probably right here jessica i'll
just say she did not seem surprised by
this news
i think it might be a combination i
think we both might be right i think she
might have some kind of
mutant gene uh some kind of freak
occurrences that have always happened
that just got activated just now
i wanna keep going on up on this but i
know we have to we will i know we will
and i'm gonna we will
we're gonna someone someone remember
this note this
so back in juan division vision
transforms back into his original look
and flies above the city see that the
portion that wand is in his live lane
fun where everywhere else is sad and
gray
that's when he sees agnes in a car and
does that zap thing
and makes her come too she tells him
he's dead you're one of the avengers
you're fishing and he's just like what
she also screams you're dead three times
you're dead
you're dead you're dead which is almost
like uh like kind of an incantation a
hex
you know you're dead you're dead you're
dead and she goes all is lost
too she says all is lost before laughing
manically like a witch
but also everyone in that section of
town was still except for her that's why
i think she's not re like she
is the mafesto or what have you because
i was like
how can no one else move but you moved
and talked before he did that to you
also how did you get there how did you
get there where were you going i'm very
excited so you guys
i don't know if you can hear me snapping
but i'm very excited so juan and pietro
talk about
what we're all asking without answering
is what she did
to the kids originally where were you
hiding all these kids up till now
what and then we see pietro's a corpse
and if i have to see one more corpse
person in this show
please no more flash corpses i'm not
ready for it i'm weird and i have really
weird attachments to these characters
um i'm weird i'm attached to these
characters vision is trying to leave the
bubble
now he's pushing through with his final
words outside the bubble
as he slowly tears apart and crumbles
dying on the grass
he says the people need help and if i
see vision
die one more time this guy they love
vision death scenes in the mcu he's like
they want to kill this man
12 times and i can't have it
he's a i know he's a walking computer
what did what do you call
a walking charger but still it hurts and
i
can't live with it okay so it's really
sad
that scene is really depressing because
darcy comes out and is like help him
he's dying i'm starting to cry and oh
he's
dying and hayward's like nah we're not
going to touch this man
so billy can hear vision and see the
pieces of what's happening through him
and wanda immediately expands the hex
bubble sucking in everything in its way
some sword agents some of those i think
all of the sword
had some of it the headquarters at the
base uh basically everything but
monica jimmy and hayward of course
because he's an evil person that has to
survive
i know couldn't be couldn't that hex
that just
nipped nipped the edge of his suv just
uh sucked in the passenger side of that
car yeah
it turns the wheels it turns the wheels
into like a beach volleyball
what a crazy car i i need it but oh my
god i am a little bit tearing up because
i am so
what a terrifying ending right like the
two
uh sword guys who turn into clowns that
moment like too many clowns
too many clowns there's too many clowns
bring out the clowns and that's the
joker
we had some mimes uh there at the end
uh i wonder what darcy's going to turn
into and if she's still going to be
attached to something big
yeah we got to talk about darcy we do it
was really sad
do you think she might turn into some
crazy like cross uh
you know merged human machine hybrid
or like i think she will because she's
also like an important person so i feel
like in the show they're gonna make her
like
a wacky waving inflatable
story right now i'm super excited to see
i loved how she goes oh fudge
too many people got sucked in and i was
like if all of them become mutants i'm
gonna be able to
i don't think all of them will become
mutants either but what like a
heartbreaking episode
um i feel like next week all my
assumptions from this week are going to
be completely overturned as well
i love this episode i loved it too
all the performance is so great uh evan
peters man like he
just gets to let loose and go crazy it's
so much fun to watch
they were like just have fun and he was
like okay i'm gonna be crazy
and i love that as the halloween episode
kind of like when you're watching
sitcoms sometimes they'll try to put in
a little scares in the halloween episode
there was a moments where i was like oh
not just the uh commercial but like yeah
the the
corpse version of pietro when he would
just like the way he acted when he was
like right behind wanda at the door
like yikes there's so much let's tear it
apart let's tear this apart let's tear
it apart
like vision apart like vision
we're going to take our first question
from stereo here we go
i think now that wanda expanded the
hex's parameter
her control over the people inside got
relatively weaker like
the residents are more aware of
themselves and their surroundings
interesting thought um so uh
yeah let's kind of boil this down into
our big question for this episode
jessica
what the [ __ ] or as we say
wanda the [ __ ] is wanda's hex doing to
the world
how what is it doing it's obviously
doing like crazy
it's it's expanding uh and wanda is
doing just what we suspected she might
do expand this wex view this west view
hex to a wider radius
threaten it appears to suck in the
entire world maybe the entire universe
into this alternate reality
uh and we should back up and say this is
almost exactly what wanda does in house
of m
the seminal scarlet witch comic series
that we suspected
one division would be based on so in
that series remember
wanda rewrites reality again and again
to try to construct a happy
family life with their children that
doesn't really exist uh
and then one of those resets is the
mutant dominated house of m reality that
is ruled over by magneto aka magnus
uh wolverine kind of goes around and
reawakens all these alternate reality
heroes
uh then there's a big battle and then
wanda says famously no more mutants and
then poof
nearly all mutants are erased from
existence in this series we've seen a
bunch of clues up until this point
there's been the way
wanda has flipped reality over and over
that's very house of m-esque
there's uh how she kind of comes off as
an out of control
threat um how it really is for the
children it's about her two kids
uh and there's this way that vision
awakens characters uh like
uh these trapped souls just that's what
wolverine does in house of m
and then there's that meson de wine wine
bottle in episode one
uh and you might have seen this week
there was a clip from uh age of ultron
for promotions for age of ultron from
2015 with elizabeth olsen aaron taylor
johnson
it was going around this week and they
asked olson like what
kind of storyline would you want to do
and she just went on and on about house
of m
and how she wanted to do house event but
she just doubted the mcu would ever go
that crazy but it appears they're doing
just that so as this west view hex
expands
um darcy earlier in the episode um
explained to monica that according to
her blood work going through that westby
barrier
twice altered her dna on a molecular
level
which is a very very big deal because it
implies that too many passes through
this hex
wall might depending on your specific
dna
might awaken some kind of supernatural
component in you uh in monica's case it
looks like
they're gonna make her photon that's the
the superhero she is in the comics
and they're setting that all up with
their mom's call sign
but in everyone else's case it could
turn them into
what the mcu might call going forward
mutants now maybe not everyone who
passes through that wall that would just
be like
so only the people who just happened to
be in the new jersey area turned into
mutants at the time
no i think there needs to be some kind
of genetic predisposition
that only gets activated now when
this uh infinity stone radiation passes
through you
and they the mc might retcon photon to
be a mutant i don't think that would be
a big deal it's kind of like
in the comics certain characters are
inhumans in addition to just being
superheroes
i i don't think it's gonna be a big deal
if it's like oh photons mutant they've
essentially in the mc you've done that
with scarlet witch she's been a
superhero without being a mutant when
she's a mutant in the comics um so as
we've suspected i think with
uh um you know instead of the no more
mutants
line juanas hex could just randomly
activate mutations in these specific
individuals across the mcu
as this hex expands and expands and she
might say something like let there be
mutants at the end
in terms of how much control does she
have over the hex as it expands
already we see in the west view anomaly
people
on the edge of the town as you get
closer and closer to ellis avenue
seem to be more kind of like glitching
they're frozen
they're just on these loops as if
they're just like background extras
just walking on a loop it's it seems to
be
localized it seems to be important to be
as close to wanda and the further
away from wanda you get uh the less
control she has
over the further reaches of it so that
might tell us how
a multiverse of madness could kind of
unleash right
so like wanda can't cognitively think
about
everything uh that is on the far reaches
of her hex
and that might tell us how some of these
mutations could just get randomly
she can't be in control over what she
activates in people
as the hex expands i just think this
rapidly expanding hex could envelop the
whole mcu
and also in addition to creating mutants
could be
what we see as a multiverse like all of
reality
is just on the same train of resetting
into these alternate states of existence
chaotically
a crisis that results perhaps in
spider-man 3
and eventually has to be fixed by doctor
strange and dr trains the multiverse of
madness which
if you look at pietro's arm he's got a
mom tattoo could be mom could be
m-o-m multiverse of madness tattooed on
his body
multi-version on his shoulder mom
that's what the mcu was doing they're
like okay we gotta put
this we gotta put a tattoo on it hey hey
this is new rockstars everything's a
clue
that is true that is true everything
everything's like
either way we know that wand is coming
back in multiverse of madness um
we don't know whether she's going to be
a villain or not she's probably going to
be some kind of uh
antagonistic threat to strange because
they're both super powerful
and in house of m she's not necessarily
a villain she's just going through
something
and they you know the avengers in the
x-men plot to kill her in that you know
she's kind of like
a threat they're trying to put down now
this episode
really reframed a lot for us like uh
going out of last episode we assumed
pietro's arrival
might have been from like a back door in
westview that we didn't see
that led to some external multiverse
like i.e evan peters was being pulled
into the mcu from the outside
fox x-men franchise but this episode
seems to contradict that assumption
right like
there's something else going on with
pietro that we'll talk about in a bit
but
everything multiversal about this hex is
coming from inside wanda
and specifically her magic magic was the
word
of this episode uh episode 4 episode 5
seemed to try to codify this in
scientific terms
cmbr radiation but in this episode it's
purely magic
that creepy commercial the yo magic
commercial like people like how does
that connect
to wanda's history it's saying like
there's another step to her history we
didn't see him which she uses chaos
magic even the official audio
description the episode described
wanda's energy blast as
her scarlet magic so jessica the
question i think we have now is
obviously we can see how this is going
to tie to doctor strange and multiverse
madness maybe spider-man 3 because it
looks like some multiverse stuff might
be happening there
maybe the timeline trippiness of loki
but what about every other mcu property
in the pipeline like one division is set
before
spider-man far from home things didn't
seem that chaotic then
we do know that vision remains stead
apart from home because he was
memorialized at the beginning of that
movie
but there's also events like black widow
falcon winter soldier shang chi
eternals hawkeye miss marvel it's hard
to it's hard to grasp
timeline wise especially because it's
coming you said it's coming before
far from home where everything seems
fine well i guess time in that bubble
also it doesn't matter it's limitless
so what could be 38 days there is
actually just an hour
and we were just that hour seeing what
spider-man was doing
so i guess it could have been a long
time in certain people
like the blip how some people come back
and it's like normal time
but i do know that it's probably just
gonna affect i was only thinking of
shang chi
that was the only thing that i was like
i feel like this is going to overlap
with that
a lot and a little bit a little bit
possibly with like iron fist
but yeah those are the only two it's
really hard to think timeline wise
because it's like i don't think it
exists it doesn't matter
like they're like it matters it matters
but like they're gonna make it
crazy yeah and by crazy it could be like
uh some of these titles are just
examples of alternate genres which in
this within this multiverse that
wanda created like shang chi is gonna be
uh
a kung fu movie you know so like that
could be
just another genre and that's how
they're able to justify genre but
you know looking at trailer footage for
falcon winter soldier doesn't feel like
a different genre
genre just feels like the kind of tone
that we saw in winter soldier in civil
war
so i think rather than each of these
titles being in their own
little pocket realities with their own
little weird glitches i think
uh what's gonna happen and it's just my
theory i wanna hear what you think about
it
i think this season is gonna end with
wanda disappearing from this reality as
her hex
kind of just bleeds back into the fabric
of reality our buddy ryan airy at screen
crush came up with this great take that
maybe the hexagons are just the general
part of the of the fabric the stitching
of all of reality in the mcu
um maybe it's that or maybe it's just
something as simple as this hex is its
own weird little thing
it just kind of like sinks back into the
earth or goes up into the sky or
vanishes or something and wanda along
with it
along with any mutants that she created
not everybody just people who had that
genetic predisposition that she had
and they're going to live somewhere else
in a separate parallel reality just for
mutants
that we're going to get our house of m
where mutants are in charge
maybe we'll even get fast spender
magneto in there but that's how
wanda's craziness won't affect all these
other things until we revisit her in
multiverse of madness
so she's just gonna go away she's gonna
live in some alternate
little bubble maybe we'll see this in
the post-credits scene or the end where
she'll open her eyes and it's
just like mutants everywhere people that
she created
all over the universe that she just
sucked up so maybe another
blip uh but not necessarily like they
dust from that reality
maybe she warps reality so that all
these people
all their loved ones and friends never
thought never knew they existed
like she kind of like brainwashes
everyone being like we never
knew our son scott summers uh
we never you know and there's just like
people all over the world they get
obliviated
uh and then they just live somewhere
else and then doctor strange confronts
her multiverse of madness and then the
worlds get merged and we get mutants in
the mcu
okay i could see that what about that
so then what about oh you said i think
in the trailer where they were turning
the
that you said that they possibly are
playing in reverse where she was
changing the car back
to normal do you think yeah is that the
case that
that is the case it was playing in
reverse we haven't seen that footage yet
that was a daytime shot of a car
uh in the trailer it was a
a um like an old 50s car in black and
white
a red wall goes through it um and that
looks like the town of west view it
didn't look like the broader world
no that's what i'm thinking that's why i
was like the only hole i could like pick
at
is the fact of like maybe i don't know
why she would suck up everything that is
the red bubble when she was
like i think at the end she's trying to
do good and turn everything back
i think that trailer shot is going to
show us the flashback of her arrival at
west view oh
how it got in how she got yeah i think
we're gonna see like some
in the next three episodes um we're
gonna cut back to when she
actually took visions because we know
we're gonna see a shot of her swooping
down in that sword facility
we saw that in trailer footage uh that
wasn't on the security feed so we're
gonna revisit that
i think we're to see her bring visions
remains and we're going to see exactly
what led to that
and then i think we're going to see that
initial warping into the 50s reality she
doesn't bring everyone with her i could
see her just
leaving her on her own and then it's
going to be the last movie but i think
what we're finding is that there
there might not be like an outside uh
multiverse reality
yet i think what this episode at least
is telling us that it's starting with
wanda that wanda might really create the
multiverse
you could argue that uh cap lived his
life in an altered timeline loki's in an
alternate timeline after end game
but i don't think the mcu yet was ready
to commit to that being the multiverse
i think wanda is really gonna birth it
in a way from her chaos magic
rewriting reality in a certain way and i
think in addition to creating that
reality she's going to be able to
extract it from this reality splinter it
into
a little bubble outside of our plane
that she can live in
jessica i'm dying to hear your thoughts
on pietro and all these other questions
that we had this episode the first we
got to think some people helped us make
it this episode
is sponsored by bluechu all right fellas
you can increase your performance and
get that extra confidence in bed at
bluetooth.com that's blue like the color
blue and chew
the you know thing that you do with your
teeth in your mouth uh blue chew brings
you the first chewable with the same fda
approved active ingredients as viagra
and cialis you can take them any time
day or night even on a full stomach
so you can be ready to go whenever an
opportunity arises
now blue chew is prescribed online by
licensed physicians so you don't have to
go to the doctor's office or wait in
line at the pharmacy it ships right to
your door in a discreet little package
uh big things come in small packages
this included they are made in the usa
and since bluetooth prepares and ships
direct they're cheaper than a pharmacy
and you don't have to leave the house
isn't that great
right now we've got a special deal for
our listeners visit bluechew.com and get
your first shipment for free when you
use our special promo code
one division just pay five dollars for
shipping that's blue blue
promo code want to vision to try it free
blue chew is the better cheaper choice
and we thank them for sponsoring this
podcast remember when you support our
sponsors you help make this podcast
possible
so please be sure to use our promo code
onedivisionbluechu.com
now we also want to thank our friends at
stereo for sponsoring us if you have
more questions and theories that we are
not getting to we probably will get to
them
in the bonus q a segment we are going to
be doing only on stereo we see about
1400 of you are listening right now
that's so exciting
can't wait to take your questions
directly jessica and i are live on
stereo as we record this
stereo is a great app with live social
conversations it's like a podcast you
can interact with it is just a podcast
you can
interact with new rockstars has three
new weekly shows on the app including
this live inside marvel every friday
morning after we're wrapped on the
youtube show jessica and i are going to
answer
questions from our stereo listeners hear
your theories
uh try to answer your questions best we
can but that's only on stereo
you can join us every monday wednesday
and friday over on the stereo app for
new rockstars three new shows including
new rockstars news with myself and
philip molina on wednesdays and our
editors show on mondays
download the stereo app and follow us at
stereo.com new rockstars or click that
link in the description again
that's stereo dot com new rockstars
we're having a great time on stereo
follow new rockstars and get notified
every time we go live
and lastly we want to thank our friends
at manscape for sponsoring this episode
manscaped is the best and mints below
the waist grooming they obsess over
their technology developments to provide
you the best tools
for your grooming experience they're
basically the sword of trimming pubes
but without the possible evil ulterior
motives
it's just hayward there's no evil little
hayward in that razor who's
trying to weaponize things because
there's no weapons it's just like a
gentle little hug
manscaped is trusted by over 2 million
men worldwide for how they redesigned
the electric trimmer
the manscaped engineering team spent 18
months perfecting the greatest ball hair
trimmer ever created it's called the
lawnmower 3.0
their third generation trimmer features
a cutting edge ceramic blade to reduce
grooving accidents thanks to advanced
skin safe technology pioneered by
manscape
the battery will last up to 90 minutes
and the waterproof technology allows you
to groom
in the shower and one of the coolest
features is that led light to illuminate
grooming areas for a closer more precise
trimming
and if you're listening to me speak
right now i want you to experience it
firsthand for yourself
get 20 off and free shipping with the
code onedivision.manscape.com your balls
will thank you
20 off and free shipping with the code
one division at manscape.com that's 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
and user code one division
all right jessica next wtf from this
episode of warner vision
wanda the is payatro's actual agenda i
don't know what accent that was i was
going for it was a
lovely one it sold it yeah
anything up to the point where wanda
calls him
how does he know that vision died also
still no ralph
and then we have another one here what
do you think it means when quicksilver
goes
to um wiccan and speed say he says
um unleash hell demon spawn
you heard what i heard yeah let's talk
about pietro so we came out of last
episode thinking marvel really just
pulled evan peters out of the fox x-men
franchise via the multiverse
now and jessica feel free to disagree
i'm leaning back towards this guy
is a con man he is someone else he is
not pietro he might be a skin
for mephisto and there's this line that
was just pointed out to us
the unleash held demon spawn that's a
big deal because it's got to be a nod to
these kids being pieces
of mephisto's soul as we have talked
about endlessly from the comics if it's
not if disney is like yeah psych it's
not
mephisto i'm gonna be how are you gonna
put these hints in there
how are you gonna say things like raise
hell dude what else are we talking about
we're talking about metal music
what are we talking about i'm so upset
that when they put that in there i was
like
if it's not mephisto i'm gonna be very
upset it's it's so crazy
and it's not just like you know a lot of
people say oh there's grim reaper clues
too it's different when someone animated
them
into uh the opening title sequence of
episode two
versus a line that the writers and the
show runner put into a line of dialogue
for a character
that was reacted to by the main
character of the show we are not
overreacting
to this they bring up devil and demon
and i understand
that she got her powers like basically
from a demon but it's like
no this is too many nods for it not to
be that like mephisto this is
too much and i don't know who to talk to
but i'm just like talk to me i'm it's
hard i'm gonna complain like i want to
put in a complaint to your manager
because okay with there's so many tells
that it's the devil and then if you're
like psych
it's pandemonium i'm going to be like
why
i'm saying here's here's what it might
be oh and some other things we should
talk about
uh this pietro seems like he's the most
confident person
right now in his pocket reality he went
from being a little confused how he got
there
to being he looks like he's totally got
a plan he even said he's like
this is why i was brought here i disturb
trouble with the brother-in-law
i gotta create drama with the rugrats i
gotta give you grief
or i gotta help you find your grief yeah
he's got this weird swagger
he knows that vision is dead he seems to
be hearing everything
he's always watching he's always
listening i think it's still
wanda i think wanda created this i i
understand wearing his skin
as just like oh i under because he has
no face it's like he recasted it's weird
but i'm just like it has to be wanda
because his his like memory goes as far
as wandas does
oh about what she he's like the last
thing i know is you scream in my
name and then it goes fuzzy and i'm like
yeah that would be true but it's also
the last memory she has of you too
and so that's probably what she put in
your consciousness of like this is what
you remember
and like that you only remember what i
remember kind of things and that's why
like when she was like who stole your
boots he was like why are you testing me
because he knew that she was doing this
i could see that i just think it's
harder for general audiences to accept
like well it's all just the protagonists
it's different versions of the
protagonists subconscious that are
attacking them
i feel like it's easier to say like
there's this nefarious entity that is
using this mask to screw with the
protagonist
and like if you it wouldn't be doing
evan peters dirty if you
said hey you're done playing quicksilver
but
we're gonna let you do one kind of fun
meta version of him in this new show
but you're gonna get to play marvel's
devil you just it was like a promotion
for him
if he gets to be mephisto that's
exciting and just see that franchise
being like
that would be exciting but i also see
that franchise being like how do we
just take from that x-men movie because
yeah it's it's definitely weird if it's
not but it feels like it could just be a
meta thing it could just be kevin feige
saying like
yeah we have access to this guy now but
we're showing like this is how we're
doing away with
what you need to be the x-men uh because
it's like
look evan peters quicksilver one of the
coolest x-men from those later x-men
movies
but when dark phoenix came out i was
like i'm kind of done
i'm ready to reboot i'm ready to reboot
i loved all these actors
they i didn't love all the actors but i
love most of them
uh and uh yeah and jessica and i have an
episode of big question coming out on
tuesday where we kind of go back through
the x-men
franchise to talk about what's essential
and who might get saved
uh in addition to evan peters and
deadpool who we know is coming uh
but like i don't i i could totally see
marvel studios saying like
we like this actor and we want to do
something fun with him um
but he's not going to be playing his
speedster self i think that would be me
to aaron taylor johnson
if he doesn't get to continue on it's
like it's kind of mean to both people
they can do both they've done both those
things
oh
have they taken like from sony and put
them in their show as the same person
i guess there's not many room to do that
a version of that was with jk
simmons but i mean sony you know kind of
said this is the same guy
so they've done that and they've
recasted like someone
i mean uh we've talked about this
they've uh yeah and norton got my castle
ruffalo so it's like they could do both
options
that's what makes me hard to believe
because i'm like
they've done both multiple times in the
past they can do both i just don't see
why they wouldn't
just try taking the quicksilver that we
love and putting it in their franchise
now yeah i mean
but who we love i think a lot of people
are still
attached to the aaron taylor johnson
quickly i get that i guess so that's
what's hard about it is i don't think we
can all assume that people everyone
knows and loves evan peters quicksilver
i think
and i'll say this hot take here he was
great in the time in a bottle scene
the eurythmic sweet dream scene in x-men
apocalypse was just the same kind of
thing but just trying to be cooler with
it
they didn't do anything new and
groundbreaking with his powers
part about aaron taylor johnson you
loved what what
there's even more that can be done i
think uh days of future past gave us a
road map for what you can do
and honestly every speedster start to
copy this afterwards flash on the
arrowverse
flash in the weed and cut of snyderverse
is like what if he could stop
time it's like no there's all these
awesome ways to show how a speedster can
move
i i don't think age of ultron did it
that much you know there was a little
moment
in that battle in the big maroon ship
they didn't really
hold on to quicksilver along age of
ultron there was like they really wanted
to push
they knew he was gonna die so they put
wanda first and foremost
and then it was ultron being weird and
liking humans now
um so to to kind of like turn the page
here on quicksilver i
or on pietro i don't think there go i
don't think they pulled him from the fox
x-men franchise
as of this episode i think it was a bit
of a wink stunt casting by marvel
and they are uh saying that this is
someone who's not pietro
maybe it's not mephisto i'm totally okay
to admit defeat if it's not
mephisto but it is someone nefarious it
could be nightmare the word nightmare
was said a couple times this episode
could be i think
we'll get into it but i think if it is
nightmare i think it's agnes
she well agnes is gonna be our next
question but before we get to agnes uh
just if by the way if you're looking for
some really really really in-depth wanna
vision theory discussion
between these new rockstars video drops
we have an awesome discord server where
24 7 new clues are being discovered
connections are being made
i'm even having trouble keeping up with
how fast they're finding stuff
really these are the takes that are too
hot for youtube i like to say
uh and you can join that discord by
becoming a patron at patreon.com
new rockstars there's a really great
community of supporters there that we
love
and you can be part of it so we just
want to give that a shout out all right
a couple questions from our stereo
listeners about agnes let's play them
you think
agnes was actually lying when she met
with vision
just to make him think that wanda was
controlling her as well
another one agnes really seemed like a
victim this episode
uh what is your take on her still being
agatha harkness yeah was she lying there
i mean has she been lying this whole
time making it look like she's a victim
or is she genuinely a victim of the west
now i that last the second question got
me through a little loop now because i
was like
oh agatha agnes whatever has had a lot
of layers for this season or this
episode
this season so let's assume that
monica or not monica god sorry that
wanda did
turn this stranger into agnes or
in the aca or from agatha darkness into
agnes that means if nightmare or
mephisto or whoever
then turned her into something deeper so
she's on like three levels deeper than
anyone else
that's where i'm like a little confused
but that whole
and i talked about this at the beginning
the fact that every other human on that
block did not move a single inch i don't
think they had
vision talking to this woman that had
the pumpkin necklace for so long a
statue basically
for so long without making note of like
notice how everyone is still on this
block
no one can move and then here's agnes
talking
like she can still talk she still moves
a little bit she's just
acting she's playing pretend and i'm
like okay so you're
you're not human you're not one of the
people that's under the speech well
here's what's kind of confused about
agnes uh as of yet we have not seen the
sword research wall identify her with a
driver's license from new jersey
she's still kind of a mystery person to
them uh which suggests
is she an actual living corporeal human
being who was sucked into this
or was she someone who helped start it
with wanda and she kind of has a
supernatural component to herself
it's one of the two it's one of the two
it can't i don't think it's because
it's both he's not doing both
like it's agnes or it's evan peters one
of those two
it's agnes yeah or evan peters from
america we do know that agnes does kind
of have a split personality but that's
personality is just like
i'm either playing the game of this uh
sitcom
or i'm reacting raw it's kind of hard to
say that there's like a third
uh identity that she's hiding you know
so what i think
is that again this is just based on this
episode uh if we are saying that she
is based on agatha harkness i think that
that at least is going to be true
like her name is actually she has a
pendant it'd be weird
like it wouldn't be that weird if
mephisto's not in this it'd be super
weird if she wasn't
at least a reference to actually and
they dressed her up as like she's
dressed up as a witch
she has a maniacal witch laugh yeah um
i think she helped want to create this
um but then it went out of her control
and now um agnes is just in it
it's one way this could go is that uh
mephisto was carried in that pendant and
he was possessed there and she toted him
around
and that now he is detached from her and
she is just lost
she's just like i don't know what to do
i don't have anyone guidance so it could
have been
acting but the way she like enunciated
you're one of the
avengers i was like this could be old
agatha harkness because she did work
with like she's like oh
also she's all basically all-knowing
like she knows about the other
she has an old-timey way of talking
you're one of those avengers would you
like a hide candy
yeah would you like a lollipop and i go
yes please
and then she casts a spell on me um i
turn into that dog that dies
and so i so it's like
oh okay the dog gets sympathy for that
vision died i guess the dog
no i still feel that it's something
about uh that dog dying vision at least
i've seen die a couple times before so
i've been desensitized to it that dog i
hate
violence dogs are really hard but it's
like
when she said that i was like okay
you're not a human i was like you're
either
agatha deep deep down or you are
mephisto just being like
[ __ ] what we need is a scene with agnes
and evan peters right we need to just
see how they
are seen with vision because i was so
when she when he did that zap that made
her come too i was like
oh thank god she's coherent because um
norm was not norm came through and was
like
my dad's sick all this being like normal
human stuff like being like
where i've been saw in the sunken place
but
like water um agnes was so
coherent that i was like okay ask her
more stuff like get
more questions yeah ask her more
specific questions please i have a list
every episode is way too short yeah
literally like crossing it off i don't
care that she's repeating you're dead
like please
we all have so many questions this
episode is 37 minutes
not enough i think at the end of the day
agnes is gonna be a witch who was
somehow
part of this she's not a pure victim
because otherwise they would have said
she was a victim by now
i think and there's a reason they left
her id off that wall
she was involved in it she not be she
may not be the total big bad though
also side note her trap her juicy
couture tracksuit
said naughty on the book
i said oh she bad
i saw oh also you'd be like oh that's
not jesus couture but there is a j on
that zipper and i
if you were a child of 2006 to 2009 you
wanted that juicy contour track suit
i was too busy with my fold out dance
dance revolution mat
in my bedroom i saw that i lost my mind
i was like
me in ice cream yes i'm so
jealous i always went to my friend
sophie's house because she had one and
her dad would like stop because they
lived in apartments and on the second
floor we were stomping
oh i'm jealous i'm sorry
you need to be in socks or bare feet to
make contact to activate those sensors
because otherwise
you're going to get miss miss miss miss
and then butterfly's going to drop you
how dare billy wait was it billy that
called out
tommy like that saying he's the cool one
i think tommy called out billy
tommy tommy was like i'm the cool one i
was like i'm gonna
shake you but you're gonna run too fast
i can't take it he's too fast he's too
fast he's
vibrating himself like yeah but um
you may have noticed uh agnes got added
to the opening credits i think that's a
big deal i think the show is saying
she is a bigger deal than just like
another member of this what she's not
norm she's not her she's not one of them
really like yeah and she was in the
fridge too she was all up in the fridge
in that lake
yeah yeah she's like steve in the full
house intro it's like steve what are you
doing with those pickles
put down those pickle steve all right we
got another question from our stereo
listeners here
why do you guys think monica was so calm
when she found out her blood and cells
were just like whoo
all over places yeah so the question
here is like
monica's blood work why did she react so
calmly to it both this week and last
week
and then they talked about i know of
your history with captain marvel what do
you think about this that one
two things one i think she's just
trained this way
like look she like especially even with
that that sentence it was so
heartbreaking that was like
i know about cells i also know that they
go into remission like she truly
doesn't care and then i think she's at
that she's like i need to help wanda
because she lost someone just like how i
lost someone like she's putting herself
in wanda's shoes
and that's where i'm like okay i guess
i'm like
you don't need to help her that bad but
but i think she's just super
professional and it was just a matter of
her being like
i gotta do what i gotta do to stop this
because hayward is obviously up to no
good
and no one's going to protect my mom's
like company like
like like i would basically and also i
still think the captain america part or
the captain in america the captain
marvel part
is because like i said before she left
and her mom is dying of cancer and she
doesn't know if she's her she stopped by
at all and
there's probably something that we
missed in between of carol
like just never coming back um always
seen nick fury but never
seen monica's mom and monica's mom was
like it's okay she'll come back one day
and then she dies of cancer
or she could have gave her something but
oh maybe
yeah i had that thought too that like
maybe her part of her mutation
is that she irradiates something and
that all of her hugs over her whole
life maybe okay so maybe that too i see
that so
what if so we might get it eventually
they did
it is but so is this show so is this
show so what if they just straight up
were carol and monica's mom went into
space doing something let's say they did
that right
they come back and everything that's
hitting monica's mom
hard it doesn't hit monica the same way
because like you said her dna is a
little different maybe
maybe this is all about hypotheticals so
what if like all that radiation that
like maria's been getting
monica's not getting monica's just been
absorbing it and then slowly
already like re doing whatever to her
cells and her daughter i think that
she already had something odd with her
i think some she had some kind of
genetic predisposition because when she
saw those scans moments after getting
blasted out of the west view anomaly
she was ready to move on she's like i
need to go to this meeting
she has some history there and i think
that history is going to be
she's a mutant and i i don't i think
that's an easy switch just for marvel
studios to say photon equals a mutant
and that's fine
i don't think anyone's going to lose
their [ __ ] um and i think she is gonna
be
she's gonna be the canary in the coal
mine of like uh
how mutants come into the mcu i think i
used the wrong thing i said lab
rat and i meant to say lab rat i think
um
you said canary in the cave in the coal
mine yeah
it's just she's getting tested she's not
getting in the boot answer the question
of i think
this whole antagonism towards captain
marvel could be as simple as
you know people know that nick fury
summoned captain marvel right as the
blip was happening
and that for five years sword sat around
waiting for captain marvel to show back
up and she did it
and there was that line at the beginning
of end game where roadie's like where
were you and she's like saving other
people on other planets
but i think we're seeing more of that i
think people who
were in the know who knew that captain
marvel existed were like
why is she prioritizing other planets
and not us
like were here and that's what gave
that's why
hayward was like you don't know what you
don't know what sacrifices we had to
make
and i was like shut up i was like
literally
stood up from my bed when he was like
it's good that you weren't here when
your mom passed because you can't handle
this job
i said boy he was just trying to agitate
right here i
so she said something that was worthy of
uh excusing me maybe
what a meaningful thing you could see
her do something like a power thing he
was like
it was totally powerful but it's also
like bring up my mom
one more time my dude i kind of
someone's dead mom
that's like the cruelest thing you could
do and she get you got your job because
she died
exactly so what you were talking about
yeah coming at me about
i got really violent when i heard that
isn't it interesting that
she brought up her dead mom quick silver
brought up the dead dad and quicksilver
got
wrecked you know like don't bring up
people's dead parents
that is true way to get [ __ ] oh my gosh
that is true
he yeah he got shot he said oh yeah he's
it's not like your dead husband's going
to die again
right i was like why would you say that
in front of the kids yeah
big dope yeah all right we're running
out of time
we want to get to a couple more
questions here so first let's talk about
this commercial this yogurt commercial
creepy as hell uh my quick take of it
was
this is just saying that wanda's magic
is a core component in the same way that
her experience with hydra
her experience was struck her with that
stark bomb that didn't detonate
with a legos where the blood
spilled where unintended consequences
and i think the fact that the kid
couldn't open the yo magic and he died
was a way of saying that wanda's magic
cannot actually raise the dead
it can create a fake reality where
they're alive again but she cannot
actually raise the dead
and also the closing part of like the
snack for survivors
it's like okay so it's just for like her
yeah it's like this is that's why he
couldn't open it but i guess
was he a survivor because like i don't
know no he couldn't that's why
yeah you can only eat it if you're a
survivor i guess what a dark
commercial one i like that shark was
like
yeah the shark said deuce is my dude and
then one ate a fish
in front of him yeah also kid's kind of
dumb could have ate that crab uh let's
keep going
yeah and then you asked about darcy what
do you think happens to darcy jessica
the moment she got sucked
i think she's just gonna turn into a
character
i like the idea of her getting powers
because then when we go
to um uh jane foster's story if she's in
it
that'd be kind of sick see my thinking
is that darcy won't get powers
so and that's how the writers are going
to explain to us not everyone who gets
hit with this
wall this hex becomes a mutant some
people
will she's only going in there and
coming out twice where monica will have
been
because i think monica is the only
double varnish she goes in
she's gonna be doing four times uh-huh
yeah
um so i loved that little moment where
she goes fudge it's a christmas story
edit
of i'm turning her oh i love it
um yeah so i think she's going to turn
into a character
she's going to be brainwashed but i
think when she comes back out it's going
to be a way of telling the audience
darcy lewis didn't turn into a mutant
you have to have a certain genetic
predisposition to be a mutant
um that's my thinking it can't just be
the hex grace mutants
hex just activates something that was
already there in people
um all right let's check into our final
segment
what the devil and i don't feel as
embarrassed talking about what the devil
this week jessica would be there's too
many
there's too many this episode seemed
like
it was now making us think that uh
pietro is a form of mepisto
the unleashed hell demon spawn was the
biggest mephisto
uh reference since uh devil's in the
details that's why i'm mad
devil in the details unleash hell demon
spawn it's like
demon spawn that's literally what they
are that is
literally what they are they are the
spawn of him like
yeah pieces of his soul
his influence over them feels corruptive
too right like he
is trying to bring out the worst in them
he is essentially what the devil is he's
trying to create chaos
uh he's trying to bring panic he's
trying to instill fear the way he
terrified those kids
and isn't it interesting how billy as a
telepath is specifically afraid of
mephisto
thinks he's a vampire right like he sees
him as someone who's
sucking from wait a minute reaching off
of them wait up wait a damn minute
wait a damn minute you oh my god i
completely forgot that damn note
oh my god it could be anyone now
it's not dracula right but well i meant
like it could be like it could be
nightmare then
um not that nightmare is a vampire but
i'm just thinking about like the night
he's afraid of the light he only comes
out and does like creepy [ __ ]
he sleeps on fire yeah he needs to be in
charge a club
yeah they eat sometimes sometimes
they're partying
and i just saw that like billy knew
something was supernatural about him and
that jump scared the way he scared wanda
at the door
he is supposed to be uh a threat i think
uh the way he knows him completely
yeah oh and there's a little detail
people are talking about that tombstone
that wanda blasts him through in that
hey maze at the end
uh there's a name on the tombstone that
is like someone who worked on one of the
fantastic four movies i think is
interesting
but the uh inscription on the bottom of
the tombstone says not on her side
oh i didn't know so that doesn't mean
it's mephisto i'm just saying that
pietro is not on her side he is on his
own side
okay because he slammed through it or he
didn't hit it he just passed it he
slapped
he slept through another oh yeah he went
through the one in the middle
yeah yeah the one in the middle all i
read was the name and i was like i don't
know who that is
i don't know her this is me this is me
on new rockstars
that's enough and then i just leave it
all right we're going to leave it there
because i got to jump on this breakdown
and we want to answer some questions
from our stereo listeners
sorry um that is happening for a long
time we did we covered a lot here
there's even more visual details i'm
gonna break down in the breakdown coming
out tomorrow thank you for your patience
there's just a lot i gotta get through
uh it's gonna be a very busy 24 hours
for me um
so we're gonna be back next week with
our breakdown of the
uh episode seven our reaction to it
there's gonna be even more crazy stuff
uh and we're gonna continue this on
stereo within our exclusive segment of
uh all of our answers to
the theories and questions that you're
presenting on stereo uh it's kind of an
after party to the after show
you can download and follow us on the
free stereo app stereo dot com slash new
rocks to be part of the fun that's where
new rock stars is doing three new weekly
live shows
just go to stereo.com new rockstars to
join the conversation thank you to jess
for joining me follow jessica at lulu
underscore clements follow me at ea boss
follow me rock star subscribe to inside
marvel wherever your podcast will close
with our favorite moment this episode
[Music]
you